scenes like these are rare in kazakhstan
protests have erupted in several cities
as outrage over an increase in fuel
prices have spread across the country
violent clashes have followed
particularly in the largest city almaty
with reports of a fire and gunshots
heard near the mayor's office where
demonstrators tried to storm the
building earlier in the week
what began as protests against fuel
crisis has turned into a wider call for
government accountability
it quickly took a political angle where
people started calling for uh free
elections of local officials uh started
calling for the ouster of top officials
in the government
so the you know they're working to get
this
kind of under control as much as they
can it's going to hurt the reputation of
the kazakh government kazakhstan has
always been fairly stable
[Applause]
the cost of liquefied petroleum gas or
lpg which is widely used as car fuel
more than doubled to 28 cents a liter
when the government lifted price caps
but amid political pressure the
government of the oil ridge country said
the price would go back to 11 cents a
liter in magistau in the west and in
other provinces
faced with a minimum wage of less than a
hundred dollars a month protesters say
the increase is unacceptable
president sacked his cabinet and
appointed a new acting prime minister
now he's calling for the unrest to stop
calls to attack civilian and military
officers are completely illegal it is a
crime and that will be punished power
will not fall what we need is not
conflict but mutual trust and dialogue
the government has argued lpg subsidies
are unsustainable in the long term
but its plan to phase out price caps
over three years is being fiercely
resisted
the central asian country long known in
the region for its political stability
now faces widespread unrest
katya lopez
al jazeera
joining us now from kiev is peter
zalmayev executive director of the
eurasia democracy initiative peter
zelmayev welcome to the newshour there
was trouble in exactly this area a
decade ago that was really messy then do
you see
something similar heading our way now
in fact yes you're right the city's
general zen a new uh sort of violence
that kazakhstan had never known in this
post-soviet uh independent history
exactly 11 years ago over 16 people died
in that city in similar protests what is
different this time is that the uh the
protests then they were confined to the
western oil producing part of the
country they have now this time spread
to the rest of the country they have
engulfed the main city of kazakhstan uh
almaty and the capital city new sultan
named after the uh de facto ruler of
kazakhstan
who remains uh
the de facto uh main political actor in
kazakhstan uh so what we're seeing now
the the the formal you know the formal
uh excuse for the protest is the lifting
of the cap on liquid that liquefied
petroleum gas uh in a country where as
you your reporter mentioned uh salaries
to you know are pretty modest by world
standards on the other hand we are
seeing increasingly uh political demands
being added to the protesters to the
point that where their main demand or
one of their main demand is for the
alistar of the government which has in
fact happened does not satisfy them any
longer so this is a very very scary
situation it's threatening to spile a
spiral out of control and then one man
may wonder what the the government
may be forced to do may be forced to
call on vladimir putin to help and step
in that is a big question
that sounds as if it's got the makings
of being a situation that is not only
dangerous to the country but dangerous
for the wider region because if the
russians walk in the chances of the
russians walking out
must be pretty slim
especially in the short term at least
as someone you know as you mentioned i'm
sitting and based in kiev in ukraine i
know uh better than uh than many people
that indeed when vladimir putin moves in
it is uh so far there's no precedent for
him to be moving out you look at moldova
you look at georgia you look at the
eastern ukraine uh and there's clearly
more than enough precedent uh in
kazakhstan for that to happen the entire
northern part of kazakhstan is a largely
russian speaking and ethnic russian
population vladimir putin has in the
past hinted that he does not view
kazakhstan as a viable sovereign nation
in fact one time saying that you know
kazakhstan does not have much experience
in sovereignty in nation building that
has sent shutters through the spines of
the political establishment for a
potential let's say scenario whereby
russia moves in and creates some kind of
a people's republic in northern
kazakhstan the way they did in ukraine
and uh you mentioned the geopolitical
situation you have to keep in mind china
that is also sitting right next to
kazakhstan it is very wary about what is
happening across the border because it
has its interests it has its billions of
dollars invested in kazakhstan and it
receives gas from kazakhstan as well
peter just to get your thoughts on three
aspects or three
areas of discussion that we're getting
as you're talking to us now we're
getting reports that the kazakh
president has been saying he would act
as tough as possible he's also saying he
will stay in the capital he is also
saying he takes over
as the chairman of the security council
your thoughts on that
well it's a in fact
the chairman of the security council is
president of former president azerbaijan
it looks like now
there's decision uh made uh
at the very top that there's need for a
very very strong action so far and there
is precedent for that in the region in
the neighboring uzbekistan in 2005 there
was an uprising in anja john it was
quelled at the cost of hundreds of
thousands of dead and so i think the
government is now smelling real trouble
uh tokyo have signed the decree ousting
the government that has not placated the
protesters
which means that they're calculating
that they will be making a very very
drastic decision it may involve uh live
ammunition against the protesters and
god knows where it will lead very very
briefly peter we're almost out of time
please would he have done that those
three things that we're now discussing
would he do that unless he thought it
would be green lit by the kremlin if he
was to ask the kremlin do you think this
is a good idea
i think he's pretty much has the backing
of the kremlin the kremlin has always
backed using force against uh peaceful
protesters okay we must leave it there
peter good to get your thoughts on this
developing story peter san may if
they're talking to us from kiev thank
you thank you